hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes We are continuing
with one rapid game per day sometimes to
if I really manage the time and today I
got a bit more rest not a lot I got up
at 4:30 a.m. uh but you know what are
you going to do and I would just like to
apologize for yesterday uh I misinformed
you regarding the chances of qualifying
for the candidates tournament it is
actually Anish giri who is leading the
Fay circuit followed by GES and only
then Wesley so uh yesterday I informed
you that Wesley so is currently leading
the FED circuit but it changes pretty
much every day so uh you know it's not
that big of a misinformation Fab is
really leading but Fab is already
qualified for the F and tournament and
Wesley again overtook lener Dominguez
Perez in the top top standings by rating
as he he drew against neppo who is high
rated and um elener Drew against mvl so
he is once again up by I think one point
so it's still very very intense we'll
see what happens but yeah just wanted to
get that out there now let's get back to
the the rapid action let's create a game
10 minutes per player and let's see uh
what do we get all right so we are
currently at 2221 and uh hopefully
slowly working our way up to
2300 uh let's see I think we get uh we
got black yesterday so yeah we got white
today uh let's uh see who our opponent
is our opponent is Epstein 64 from
Russia all right so we're going to open
with E4 uh still working on some other
openings uh you guys requested uh that I
try out something other than E4 but for
the moment I I'm still not ready to
employ it so we're going to go D4 grab
the center Knight C3 and we'll see what
he does okay so he goes for Knight to F6
which um is very very interesting uh the
most popular I believe is still Bishop
to B4 but uh yeah we can play this many
many different
ways uh we're gonna how do we how do we
play
it uh yeah let's go Bishop G5 let's go
Bishop
G5 and uh there's even a fun uh yeah
okay with Bishop to
B4 that's very interesting yeah this is
uh I think this is a very very
complicated
line
uh that goes H6 Bishop H4 G5 we go back
and then yeah he goes Knight E4 so not
really an expert on how to play this but
he will he will show us how to play it
okay so we can obviously capture but uh
we're going to go back and see what
happens if he uh if he actually goes for
Knight D4 he will put pressure on our
pieces here we're going to go Knight to
E2 uh kick away the Knight and uh then
continue or we're going to force him to
start capturing on C3 he'll probably go
C5 with some Queen to A5 to put even
more pressure here uh so we'll see what
happens now he goes Knight to C6 he
wants uh what does he want okay so he
wants if he
captures yeah I'm kind of thinking C5
was the way to go here but
okay uh let's uh let's ask some
questions what do you do with the
bishop
so is this
fine yeah it kind of looks
fine uh on the other hand if I play B4
we're no longer castling Queen side and
let's say B4 Bishop to B6 I play F3 he
captures here I can capture with the
knight uh this would leave my D4 Pawn
sort of stranded so I might have to
capture with h to here and then I'm
going to have this weird setup here so
but it's uh you know maybe not the end
of the
world yeah let's go for
it now he's going to capture here first
very
interesting okay so he will show us why
why this is
better to tell you the truth I have no
idea why this would be better as we're
going to consolidate with
C3 he probably goes for some Pawn break
with Pawn to F6 but okay so he goes for
this first we're going to play
B5 okay so he does get the the F5 Square
for his Knight and then he's going to
harass the pawn this way okay makes
perfect
sense makes perfect sense and we are
going to have to figure out a way how
to how to develop
here yeah probably F3 yeah probably F3
shift our Bishop back to F2 to add
support to this pawn and then challenge
the F5 Knight with Knight to G3 yeah
that seems like the way to go all right
so he's playing uh he's playing much
faster but you know since he he he he's
the one that chose this opening it would
make sense that he he knows it better
okay so he plays A4 um maybe I should
have played A4 first that's true now my
Pawn could become a bit vulnerable but
yeah okay show
me let's
see okay so he
captures capturing with the bishop is I
guess okay without ruining my Pawn
structure but I also might uh open up
the H file yeah let's make it
interesting since I really don't know
how to play this uh yeah
okay yeah that's not bad that's actually
not
bad yeah and Bishop to
D7
so yeah this is actually very nice very
nice from him let's go Rook B1
then we're going to play Bishop to E1
and hide our King over to
F2 yeah now C5 maybe maybe C5 no he goes
here he wants to go after the pawn so we
have to we have to throw in a queen
D3 which is nice we covered the pawn and
also we stop some Bishop to C3 nonsense
I don't know if it's a move but maybe
you know maybe at some point it could be
a move all right so we are um the King
on E2 looks weird but once we play
Bishop to E1 and put the King on F2
should be okay yeah so he he says uh
yeah this is fine now we don't have to
play Bishop D1 we could actually shift
our Bishop over to
E3 uh to keep everything nicely defended
yeah he might play C5 now in order to
allow captures and then have pressure
against my A4
Pawn
ah yeah that's nice that's very
nice but how is he handling Bishop to E1
followed by followed by Bishop to
B4 yeah let's let's go for
that all right I almost feel like I've
Consolidated uh which is I know a weird
thing to say with a king on E2 yeah of
course he's not going to Castle or
anything he just goes here so let's grab
more space here
and now our King should be completely
safe now our King should be completely
safe yeah although I don't like my king
on F2 now with this uh Bishop
here so what would be the the correct
way to play
this something like if four maybe with
the King on
F3
no have to be a little bit careful
here um let's go Bishop to C5 yeah
that's a that's a nice move although
maybe we don't have to rush it
yeah but maybe that's yeah the B5 Pawn
is hanging we do have to tend to that
yeah we have to go Bishop
C5 like
this and really get our King off of this
diagonal it looks very scary to tell you
the
truth all right so he goes after the
pawn he really wants to attack it now we
now we play King F2 and we open up the
bishop there there there we
go now we're defending everything it's a
really weird weird
position yeah I don't want to capture
here uh as he will capture okay I messed
up his Pawn structure a little bit but I
really like controlling this diagonal so
if he wants to regain control of this
diagonal I want him to capture on C5 and
then I get these two pawns here which
kind of weakens my E5 Pawn but I I'm not
completely against playing F4 at some
point
so yeah let's uh let's do
that and now okay so he captures let's
see what he had in
mind what did he have in mind something
like
C6 yeah C6 doesn't look terrible because
then he gets access to the C5
Pawn now he's going to go after C5 this
way okay so this is nice this is nice
Definitely but now okay only rook and
Bishop are attacking the pawn so we can
actually move our
Queen uh with Tempo is he threatening
anything else no he's not yeah let's do
this all right so we're down uh we Al we
already lost half of our
time but uh yeah I think this is fine we
don't we do do we rush C6 or do we want
him to play C6 what do we what do we do
here
now we play C6 here definitely we play
C6
definitely and then we get our Bishop
into the game and hopefully the Rook
yeah
okay yeah this is not very interesting I
thought he will
capture is B6 a
move
yeah let's go let's go
B6 since if he plays B6 he pretty much
closes the position but yeah maybe I
allow B6 by him because it also leaves
his Bishop absolutely useless
here I don't know it's a very difficult
position
yeah probably not advancing the pawn to
B6 was the way to go but he is out
playing me on time yeah he's playing
much faster so I have to ask some
questions hopefully unpleasant
ones yeah okay so he captures here as he
should we're going to capture
here there we
go and we go here yeah we attack his
Rook a little
bit
what does he play
then yeah he's always going to be able
to C to just Castle away so that might
be an
issue yeah let's do
it so he has to tent to The Rook
probably something like
this
and we go Bishop to D3 so we don't care
about Rook to C7 yeah probably that yeah
we go Bishop D3 defend our
Pawn um yeah is this is this of
any yeah let's go here
first
let's go here
first this King on F2 is ugly I
know yeah if I can trade down okay so
he's going to play that of course he is
we're going to go here uh put some or no
he captures captures and then what he
goes King C6 attacks my rook and Bishop
I go Rook here he attacks it no that's
not not going to work at
all yeah we have to we have to capture
here okay so he goes after the pawn
which is nice we go
here and he might play yeah he I kind of
missed this but
uh I kind of missed this but let's say I
sacrificed it for activity no he's going
to go here
okay uh now we go
here yeah let's go after the
pawn all right two minutes is enough to
play a
reasonably a reasonable end game yeah
it's probably going to double up on the
C file which is
fine or he goes to C3 now now he goes
here
okay uh now we have to play
C4 otherwise that pawn is just terrible
for for a very long time yeah let's
capture with the
bishop yeah of course you'll play that
let's go here he's going to give a check
we don't really care about the
check
or do we I don't know if we
do yeah okay he will give a
check now some Rook B7 action becomes
possible yeah okay so he's going to sort
of stop
that what do we play what do we play
that's the real
question yeah let's go let's go after
the pawn let's force a trade
here yeah this is actually bad yeah he
just captures captures delivers a
check and then he goes after my Pawn
here yeah that's the maybe the real
problem I don't know we'll see okay so
he captures now he gives a
check no he doesn't he goes after this
okay so we're not going to allow
it do we do we have a way of not
allowing it
all
right
okay let's go here still not allowing
him he he now has to
capture okay so he's going to go for
that go
[Music]
here and
here okay you can do
that
here go
here you will play this threaten mate I
will have to play
G4 or I can trade Rooks but uh yeah
trading Rooks isn't all that
impressive
let's go
here and
here yeah we don't really have time for
that yeah we have to go
here maybe tries to trick me and deliver
mate 35 seconds not the best not the
best all right we'll
see okay so he wants uh me to take the
pawn for whatever
reason
okay fair enough fair
enough let's go after the pawns okay 20
seconds 20 seconds let's do
this we can do it in 20
seconds
not a
problem take
here yeah let's go after the pawn if G4
we going we're going after the
pawn now he plays it like this
okay we're going to play G3 since the
second rank is
covered and uh he can't play F5
otherwise he loses the Rook so we're
going to start advancing our
King all right 17 seconds really really
really hard to play Let's go here let's
not yeah not the maybe not the
best yeah let's go
here okay let's go
here
okay very nice let's stop that all 5
Seconds yeah that's not going to work at
all 3 seconds all
right yeah definitely not the
best
yeah he has he has Rook F1 no he's not
going to do
it oh of course yeah he doesn't allow me
up the board yeah I allowed myself to go
down on time a little bit U too much
here
so uh didn't really work out my way uh
but he was better in all the positions
and I couldn't really get anything going
and that's why I had to spend so much
time but yeah let's see what we could
have done better okay so this is
fine yeah this is perfectly fine okay
Knight C6 A3 B4 yeah we played that uh
pretty
much all well okay what was okay so H4
he wants H4 right away yeah the Knight
here really really does call for H4 but
okay F3 did did seem like a like an over
push but still all pretty much z z
territory yeah King is fine here like we
said so everything is okay here Queen D3
yeah
okay uh G4 okay to to keep the weakness
on H6 we play Bishop here Bishop
here yeah so we played everything
everything precise here and now after
this uh King to F2 move now even after
this Rook move uh we are winning yeah we
I did play King F2 he play captures
captures Queen here Queen C3 yeah so we
played everything
precisely okay G4 sort of better but B6
still very much better for
me and uh yeah okay so here Bishop to B5
yeah I did consider Bishop to B5 I can't
remember why I decided against it yeah
probably I I was worried about Rook to
C7 then Queen D6 check okay you capture
captures Rook captures okay King
F2 okay so yeah this is
uh yeah just keeping him in the center
and also putting pressure on this Pawn
but what if
check here and you capture the pawn what
is the idea okay it's just Rook C1 so
yeah that's uh I should have played with
with activity yeah that's the that's the
real problem I played Rook to B8 still
better for me okay but here yeah Queen
to D6 check again I was I was afraid to
play this move uh Rook C7 okay this is
fine this is fine yeah here okay F4
first yeah all the moves we were
considering but we just uh didn't pick
the the right continuation so yeah
better to improve the activity of the
king I played C4 I thought this was the
way to go I thought maybe it was yeah
but on the other hand the bishop Pawn
combo uh is sort of an antidote for both
of his Rooks yeah here I just sort of
allowed him into the game and now he's
the one who is actually better it's a
plus one okay not spectacular anything
but still an advantage for
him yeah okay and here Rook to B4 here I
was already down on time Rook to D2 is
the the way to
go uh what was I afraid of with Rook to
D2 why wasn't I going after the pawn
yeah that's really
weird yeah still everything is a draw
here he just uh spent way too yeah okay
F4 F4 loses due to Rook
B1 yeah he also had that and then if
G4 oh he just stops he just stops the G3
Square yeah very nice yeah so we also
miss that okay captures captures now
it's again a draw a draw draw draw draw
draw draw draw draw draw nothing
spectacular here yeah and now with this
we we we lost the thread and here he got
away but yeah here I was playing down
too much time uh too long time so
nothing uh nothing really wrong with the
game it was perfectly fine but it took
me way too long to actually make the
moves and I ran into I ran into trouble
later on yeah you shouldn't allow
yourself to go down below a minute maybe
in some positions okay with Queens on
the board if it's a king hunt maybe you
can but if you still have to play like
50 moves of the end game and uh you know
if you you will have to rely on
pre-moving some of the moves like I have
uh then it's not going to go your way uh
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it hope some of you learned
something from it and uh yeah if you if
you feel like there's something that I
really should have improved here or
maybe there's a section where I'm uh
really playing poorly maybe also make a
suggestion on how to improve on that uh
we are all here here uh to learn uh so
yeah big congratulations to Mr Epstein
64 very nice game and yeah that's it for
for today's rapid game maybe I will play
another one we'll see how it goes uh
until then uh see you in the next
one